was ist Trader 2021 habe ich versucht
mich über 10 Videos hinweg von nichts zu
einer Rolex hoch zu arbeiten vom
sneakery selling über aktienhebeln oder
Pokern haben wir so ziemlich alles
ausprobiert um am Ende dann tatsächlich
eine Rolex in den Händen zu halten und
sie an einen Zuschauer zu verschenken
dennoch ich glaube dass ich das ganze
noch mal toppen muss mehr Risiko
ausgefallenere Methoden und vor allem
ein höheres Ziel ich begrüße euch zur
ersten Folge von Porsche trade ab heute
tauchen wir das Goldfeld das ist der
Grund warum ich so aussehe und warum ich
auf dem Golfplatz stehe aber lasst mich
erklären wie auch in Staffel 1 suche ich
nach verrückten Methoden Geld zu
verdienen und als wir letztes Jahr
angefangen haben mit Homies immer wieder
auf eine Driving Range zu gehen und
hunderte Golfbälle an einem Tag
wegzuballern ist mir eine Frage bekommen
was passiert mit den Bällen die nicht
auf einer Driving Range sondern auf
einem wirklichen Golfplatz einem 18 Loch
Golfplatz verhauen werden und zwar so
verhauen werden dass man sie nicht
wieder
und vor allem gibt es eine Möglichkeit
damit Geld zu verdienen nach ein
bisschen Recherche bin ich auf folgende
Erkenntnisse gestoßen es gibt ca 700.000
Golfer in Deutschland und 435 18 Loch
Golfplätze auf diesem Plätzen werden
durchschnittlich
22.470 Runden im Jahr gespielt also
vermutlich auch einige Bälle verloren in
Amerika zum Beispiel werden insgesamt
pro Jahr 300 Millionen Bälle verloren
und runtergerechnet auf Deutschland und
Deutschlands Golfplätze müssen es ca 7,5
Millionen sein wie viele davon aber
wirklich in den seenlampen und dazu noch
brauchbar zum Wiederverkauf sind keine
Ahnung was wir aber wissen es gibt
einige Firmen die sich genau darum
kümmern also muss eigentlich Geld zu
holen sein Golf ist für mich auch wenn
es vielleicht nicht ganz so ist ist für
mich ein reichensport diese Bälle Kosten
1 2 3 oder sogar noch mehr Euro und die
Leute ballern die einfach weg
professionellen Leute treffen im
Zweifelsfall nicht oder selten sehen
spielen aber nicht nur professionelle
Leute und genau das ist der Punkt an dem
wir angreifen was haben wir also gemacht
wir haben bei allen Golfplätzen
angerufen und gefragt ob wir während
können und zu unserem Glück hat einer
kompromisslos zugesagt
guten Tag
sind Golfbälle die Aussehen kommen das
sagt der Name schon die Bälle gilt ist
erstmal aus dem Wasser zu holen Sie dann
wieder aufzubereiten zu sortieren und
schlussendlich dann zu verkaufen
haha was ja auch noch dazu kommt die
sehen müssen ja in Schusslinie sein wir
konnten das auf Google Maps so etwas
erahnen aber ich weiß nicht wie schlecht
man sein muss um den Tümpel zu treffen
also desto mehr der in der Schusslinie
liegt natürlich desto besser desto
länger dann niemand getaucht ist und die
Dinger rausgeholt hat auch besser und
all das wissen wir nicht es kann sein
dass uns unermesslicher Reichtum
erwartet und es kann sein dass das hier
der absolute Reinfall wird egal was
Stimmung geht wieder los ich bin
unendlich Pant und freue mich riesig auf
die nächsten Folgen vergesst nicht den
Kanal zu abonnieren um all diese nicht
zu verpassen und lasst mir gerne ein
Like da wenn euch dieses Video gefällt
ein Platz war hat uns kurze Hand im
Golfplatz zum See gefahren und dann
waren wir da unser Arbeitsplatz für
diesen Tag vielleicht so 50 Quadratmeter
groß und ganz am äußersten Rand von dem
Golfplatz und hoffentlich voll mit
weißem Gold also die Golfbälle sind
durch die Wasseroberfläche zu sehen
gehen wir mal davon aus dass es ganz
schlecht ne
die Bälle 20 Cent wert sind dann haben
wir 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 30 40 50
die ich hier so sehe also 10 € sehe ich
von oben im Sommer ohne alles einfach in
Badehose und das Bargeld aus dem Wasser
holen aber es ist kein Sommer wir im
Februar um die fünf Grad deswegen
springt in den Neoprenanzug
auf dem Weg sich kostenloses Geld
abzuheben mir geht's in dieser Rabe aber
das Geld lacht mich an
oh Alter
du greifst einfach irgendwo rein
und holst sofort was raus
[Musik]
und genau das war der Moment in dem ich
gemerkt habe das könnte funktionieren
drei Bälle Alter Alter
hier liegt alles voll Alter meine unter
meinen Füßen überall ist das Ganze
Bargeld hier unten ach
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich schon wieder den ganzen
Sack voll
was kostet so ein Ball hochpreisigsten
Bälle und die nachher auch im Video
verkauft das meiste Geld bringen also
jetzt in dem Zustand kannst du die
bequem noch für 250
2,2,50 € verkaufen fünf Bälle in einer
Hand ich liege in diesem drecksümpel
hier liegt einfach Bargeld es könnte
sein dass diese Hand gerade 10 € wert
war fühlt sich zu leicht an schon fast
money Glitch
obwohl wirklich eine Menge Bälle dabei
waren die richtig gut aussahen haben
sich immer mehr Zweifel bereit gemacht
weil ich einfach nicht einschätzen
konnte ob sie wirklich was werden
einfach mal Urlaub in Deutschland machen
und diese Zweifel sollten sich zumindest
teilweise auch bestätigen ich würde
sagen ich habe jetzt ungefähr ein
Fünftel des Tümpels nicht war clean
gemacht aber so abgetastet so locker
hier ist so viel mehr drin kriegt man
alles nicht alleine hin ich brauche
irgendeine Lösung dafür dieses gesamte
Ding hier einmal auf den Kopf zu drehen
und alles rauszuholen was da ist ja
dicker hier ist wieder alles voll ich
bin jetzt hier rüber gegangen weil Leo
gesagt hat das könnte im Video satt sein
wenn ich nur da vorne bin aber es ist de
facto so es hat sich überhaupt nicht
gelohnt aus diesem Bereich wegzugehen
weil er alles voll war aber hier ist
jetzt halt wieder quasi unberührtes
Territorium und hier greift man wieder
ganz entspannte Vierer Hände das ist
wirklich schlecht laufen und diese 200
Bälle 50 € wert sein dann haben wir
gerade einen Stundenlohn von 50 €
gefunden hast du das ein Tag 8 Stunden
400 €, das ist alles noch nicht fertig
abgesucht und was mir zu dem Zeitpunkt
noch nicht bewusst war es gibt noch
einen zweiten See ich denke für heute
ist das gewesen sein deine sehr gute
Casey die Frage ist aber jetzt wie viel
Geld ist das wirklich wie gut sind die
Bälle in welcher Qualität sind die Bälle
wie lang liegen die da drin wir haben
gehört seit Jahren war hier niemand mehr
drin haben wir einen Gewinn oder haben
wir einen Gewinn jetzt heißt es Bälle
mit nach Hause nehmen sauber machen vor
allem Bälle verkaufen das hier ist die
Ausbeute von einer Stunde nach
Golfbällen tauchen die große Frage ist
jetzt aber wie viel Geld konnten wir
umsetzen wie viel Geld konnten wir aus
dem See holen was wir schon erfahren
haben sie sind sehr unterschiedlich viel
wert aber wie findet man jetzt raus
welcher wie viel wert ist dafür habe ich
den einzig wahren Max brummendorf
Angestellter von Max und Teil dieses
Büros und begnadeter Golfer um mich zu
sagen der beste Golf von Deutschland und
ich habe hier schon mal gespielt hier
diese Reihe von Teil lässt ist die die
man haben will und was kostet so neu die
kosten 5 € pro Stück genau ja weg ja ich
hoffentlich nicht so viel drin ist nein
aber ich hätte auch nicht gedacht dass
sie das nie lernen das ist eigentlich
sehen wenn man vernünftig Golf spielen
kann trifft man die nicht okay also
eigentlich sind die voll aus dem Spiel
aber es gibt ja auch Rentner
wir gehen jetzt vor indem du erstmal die
ganzen dunklen würde ich sofort
wegschmeißen die vier Marken würde ich
erstmal beiseite kommen da gibt's
natürlich dann auch wieder Bälle von
denen die nicht so gut sind oder nichts
mehr wert aber
ich denke bei manchen sogar ich habe die
da reingeklappt ne weil ich die so
wiedererkenne grundsätzlich sortieren
wir nach drei Kriterien Alter je älter
desto schlechter das erkennt man an der
gelblichen Färbung ein neuer Ball
strahlt schön weiß Härte und natürlich
kommen da noch mehr Kriterien dazu aber
desto weicher der Ball desto höher die
Qualität jeder Golfer wird gerade völlig
ausrasten weil das ist mit Sicherheit
nicht so aber irgendwie so ne irgendwas
es kommt auf die härter an ob weich oder
hart toll und schlecht und ganz wichtig
die Marke besonders viel wert sind Bälle
von Marken wie tightlist Titel ist
rixone also das ist einmal hier pro
Vereins ist die beste Serie von Titel
ist und von Tailor may zweite führende
golfmarke und da ist das beste Modell
tp-5 okay 30 richtig gute 50 sehr gute
aber wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen
alt und 50 markenbälle die ist nicht
Endstufe zwei geschafft haben was
glaubst du was die richtig gute Kiste
hier so pro Golf beibringt also ich
würde sagen pro Golfball wahrscheinlich
so zwei Euro weil die sind alle gut im
Schuss also nicht die finden würde würde
ich genauso aussortieren und mein Weg
wieder packen und weiter spielen also
safe kriegt sie für zwei drei Euro
verkauft und die wahrscheinlich so unter
knapp 1 Euro oder drunter und bei denen
bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr
sicher die kriegst vielleicht in so
einem 30er Paket Bälle irgendwie los das
hier 30 ja die hier 20 ja die alle für
zusammen
60 ich glaube wir müssen noch mal hin
wie fühlt man sich wenn man so krass
geschlagen hat ziemlich gut ja